i feel like i have to do something like
go to different places clearly it's not
working whatever i'm doing
kim kardashian's changing her approach
to dating following her breakup with
pete davidson yep
kim's love life was a hot topic on the
late late show host james corden asking
how the mogul as famous as she is how
she finds guys you are currently single
happily single yes currently single now
i sympathize in many ways i cannot begin
to imagine how
kim kardashian looks for a partner how
do you find it's not that you're gonna
bump into someone in ralph's you know
how do you do it do you do you get set
up by friends do you go on a dating app
how does how does kim k get a date
i haven't really thought about it
because i just i'm not looking i just
want to chill for a minute yeah and it's
only been a minute kim and pete split in
august after nine months of dating you
just gotta roll with it but not long
after a source told et the reality
star's ready to get back out there
adding quote kim is definitely open to
dating again and her friends and family
would love to set her up and think it's
so fun why not
and while she's open to love kim knows
she has to change things up i think my
next route will
i feel like i have to
do something like go to different places
clearly it's not working whatever i'm
doing right and get this she doesn't
seem interested in her next partner
being famous i feel i don't know maybe
like a hospital and meet a doctor
what
a a law firm i think it's going to be
like scientists
neuroscientists biochemist
doctor attorney that's
right maybe what i envision i like where
your mind's at here so if we ever see
like paparazzi shots of like kim
kardashian spotted at nasa we'll be like
ah
she's back out at she's not back out at
it she asked in the meantime it seems
kim's enjoying the single life
yeah bible it's a great look
the kardashian star just stepped out for
beyonce's roller disco themed b-day bash
and her sis chloe shared this snap of
them with their good friend lala anthony
oh and coco had the most fitting
[Music]
captions now put your hands up
[Music]